So the [UNKNOWN] agent figured out that handle is fixed should go
beneath object enables drinking, but not beneath object is liftable.
So the agent will put handle is fixed here, in this particular explanation.
This is correct. If the agent has background knowledge,
it tells it that the reason handle is fixed is important is,
because it makes the object manipulable, which in turn enables drinking.
Then the agent can insert this additional assertion here in the explanation.
Even more, if the agent has additional background knowledge that tells it,
the defect of the object has a handle, and that the handle is fixed, together
make the object orientable, which is what makes the object manipulatable, then
the agent may come up with a richer explanation. The important point here is,
that as powerful and important as classification is, it alone is not sufficient.
There're many situations under which explanation too is very important.
Explanation leads to richer learning, deeper learning.